Patriot's for the gift that keeps on
giving they're always interesting Tom
Curren the Patriots insider friend BC
sports Boston joining us when did you
get word that Cam Newton was now a New
England Patriot Tom Dan right after I
climbed off my jet ski
it's a 1997 Kawasaki and I just was
telling Fritzi I took it for a run cuz
we got an indicator light on I came in
and my boss says you're gonna write on
Cam Newton I said no so I'm on vacation
but uh yeah it was a surprise because as
much as guys like Mike Lombardi and
folks like that said keep an eye on Cam
Newton I had been told in April that I
am safe to continue along the lines of
this isn't gonna happen but I think the
price dropped enough to where both sides
said yeah what do we got to lose yeah I
don't think cam had any leverage but I
was wondering how much they liked him
maybe in April and how much they loved
him here at the end of June I think they
loved him at one point zero five million
with incentives that to me has to be the
absolute tumbler that needed to fall
into place they are so tight against the
cap that there was no other way they
could pull this off the end so if Cam
Newton was seeking to be and that number
7.5 million that he is able to hit if he
hits his incentives is interesting
because that's what Marcus Mariota will
make with the LA Raiders
issue Las Vegas women hell they are
that's what he's gonna make with the
Raiders so they had to get up to that
level with Cam the question is is he 15
cam is he 18 cam or is he the one who
either sucked in 16 or was hurt in 17
and 18 and 19 but if I was gonna look at
Cam Newton this year and I said he'll be
starting for the Patriots in the
playoffs he'll be on the bench with the
Patriots he won't be in the NFL or he'll
be on another team what would you pick
boy you know you love doing these things
do you don't give me any preparation
time he'll be playing for the Patriots I
don't think the Patriots are going to
the playoffs but again these are
percentage-wise guess
I would say that's the most likely
scenario whether he's starting or not
it's gonna be fascinating to watch this
play out dan one thing that's
fascinating to me about this though is
the timing
nobody knows news cycles like the New
England Patriots the Patriots did not
have control of the announcement of the
penalty that was going to come out they
did have control of when they could leak
out the signing of Cam Newton did they
sign Newton because they loved them did
they sign Newton because they always
plan to did they sign Newton because
they said you know what let's do a
little bit of wag the dog action here
and get ahead of this so that they have
to digest Cam Newton and not all the
things I've done in the past I'm right
there with you because it's New England
and the timing of this with Cam Newton
Sunday night on June 20 that offense has
really it felt like they become more of
a running team and I don't know if cam
like if you said if stidham's in there
the offense is this if cam is in there
they're the offense is this how much of
a seismic shift is that going to be I
don't think it'll be that seismic I
think that they're already planning to
alter the offense to make it more
dynamic more mobile to challenge on the
edges of the defense at the end of the
line of scrimmage more put those outside
linebackers defensive ends in choose
situations make people suck up and have
to defend the run you know with Brady
you couldn't do those things he could do
a million things that nobody else can
Cam Newton Jared stone Brian who are
included but I think the dynamic aspect
of the offense is an important one that
they've missed out on been replaced by
something pretty good but they need to
start getting toward that trend and I
think they're looking forward to it and
are starting to alter their offense in
this offseason to do it by the way back
to the violation the oh by the way
violation that's a million dollars in a
third round draft pick now the story
that they were filming this as a part of
was the do your job yes
so was the person doing his job and he
got fired
for it yeah the the job that wasn't
properly done was looping in the
Cincinnati Bengals see they were at the
Brown Stadium they called the Browns and
said we're sending a news reporter or
we're sending a reporter and a cameraman
we're gonna get some b-roll footage of
the scout on the sidelines that cool
with you Cleveland yes it is well
they're sitting there and since that is
like those are the Patriots and they're
filming our sideline right in front of
us and the guys basically smoking a
cigarette and watching us what are we
supposed to do here so that's where it
went downhill so the job not done was in
them not dotting the rise crossing their
T's and thinking that brandishing a
video recorder if you're wearing a
Patriots shirt is a good idea yeah but
you wouldn't think they would be doing
something wrong if you're wearing a
patriot shirt like you nobody would be
that obvious trying to do something
right but I think that over the 15 years
the hue and cry about the Patriots has
dropped the bar of expectation so low
that people think the Patriots are
capable of absolutely anything so what
better cover to use them to be
ultimately it's like talking to Tom
Curren the Patriots insider any
correspondence with t be 12 down in
Tampa I could just tell you this he is
again loaded for bear to prove a lot of
people wrong I think that he sense is
that people are circumspect about his
chances definitely that they don't think
the Rob Gronkowski will be Rob
Gronkowski and it's the same fuel for
the fire that we especially saw all
through his career but you know in 2018
when they made their Super Bowl run what
do you think of that I don't even know
if we're gonna get to this though but
you gotta tell what's your take on the
workouts I got no issue with it well I
was an object yes exactly and but I
don't know if the NFL has a problem then
find the team or do I mean do something
if then let the team let it be a team
matter here of what they want to do
state by state
but I I don't know it doesn't look good
doesn't look it doesn't it doesn't but I
mean that is the look it doesn't look
good yeah and it wouldn't look good if
Alan sells the NFL's medical director
who's a neurologist and does a great job
in that arena doesn't say something
about we'd rather not see you do that
same thing with the NFLPA if they don't
say anything at all and we have a
pandemic sweeping the nation and
triaging beds and ventilators PPEs and
everything else running out well then it
doesn't look great but when we really
think of the practical aspects of it and
what we know about this and the guys
outside thirty yards from the people we
thrown the ball to and we know all these
things to be true I just don't
understand why we get our panties
punched about it if I said do a belly
check and I got a true answer would you
rather have Cam Newton or Tom Brady if
you could get Tom Brady for 1.05 million
you got you gotta take Brady at a salary
and you get Cam and his salary he'll
take him here I mean look it's it's that
guy who loves a bargain they are
spending the end between the four
quarterbacks for I am lowary Jamar Smith
Stidham and Hoyer it's like three point
two five million there are and I counted
up 30 quarterbacks in the NFL who are
making three million or more this year
so they are spending nothing on that
position and that's a great spot for
Bill to be in it's especially a great
spot when they head into 2021 if the
salary cap number drops down because the
Patriots don't have a Pat mahomes or a
dak Prescott etc depen what's it like
though when you get a text back you know
when you're in love and then you're
waiting for that person to send you a
text back and then Brady send you a text
back and then do you giggle or something
yeah yeah do you do like our mo geez cuz
I'm big on emojis less words to write
I'm just I never thought of myself as an
exclamation point guy but I'm a bigger
exclamation point guy because a period
just doesn't look enthusiastic enough
yeah yeah thank you can't just say
thanks yeah
Chris he knows that you can't just say
my wife we have this conversation all
the time I'll tell her I'm doing
some initial setback tks like what are
you so pissed about nothing I just said
thanks you pick the wrong guy
yeah it's great to talk to you enjoy
your vacation enjoy your vacation happy
Independence Day to you and the fellas
thank you
that's Tom Curren he is for effort he's
an effort guy he's the Patriots insider
for NBC Sports Boston